allez c'est aujourd'hui c'est le grand
jour le jour où je t'annonce mon projet
le jour où je te révèle mon mon grand
secret on reprend là où on s'est arrêté
hier elle n'est pas une elle est deux
désormais le temps de son règne approche
elle s'apprête à se réver au suus du
monde à tes yeux émerveillé par sa
double splendeur qui est-elle qu
est-elle avec est-elle que je suis sur
le point de te révéler va changer ta vie
à jamais car je t'annonce aujourd'hui
l'avement de ma bière j'ai fait de la
bière deux bières alors évidemment j'ai
pas fait ça tout seul j'ai fait ça avec
j vais de la chaîne une bière et j'y
vais mais je te raconte tout ça bientôt
alors c'est bière la PR ire elle
s'appelle glam métal c'est une Nepa donc
une New England IP avec une jolie
couleur et des goûts fruités tendan
exotiqu et la deuxième c'est la black
métal une bière noire très noire un
stout au noix noble avec une touche de
framboise tu as envie de les goûter
évidemment et ben il y a deux
possibilités soit tu les commandes sur
unebièregiv.com soit tu es sur Paris et
là bah tu viens à la grosse soirée de
lancement qu'on va organiser je te
raconte ça très vite abonne-toi pour pas
rater ça